nous poursuivons nos travaux sur le
Foncia agricole dans les outre-mer avec
un second focus juridique en compagnie
des représentants du Conseil National
des Barreaux le CNB pour cet écran je
remercie de leur participation à mettre
Nathalie Jay on s'est bâtonnet de
Saint-Pierre de la Réunion et
vice-présidente de la Commission
prospective et innovation du CNB maître
Yannick Louis de Bar membre de la
commission des affaires européennes
internationales de et de la commission
règle et usage du CNB mesdames dans un
premier temps vous allez avoir la parole
pour un propos liminaire afin de
présenter vos observations sur la base
du questionnaire qui vous a été adressé
pour préparer cet échange dans un second
temps un autre rapporteur vivait de
Lopez puisque j'excuse le sénateur de
Mayotte qui n'a pu participer totalement
à nos auditions
interviendront avec nos collègues pour
vous poser des questions demander des
précisions complémentaires le cas
échéant il est précisé d'ores et déjà
que nous sommes également preneurs si on
ne couvre pas tous les champs au travers
de cette audition de contribution écrite
que vous jugeriez
utile et nécessaire au regard des
questionnements que que se pose la
délégation sur ce sujet du foncier
agricole en outre-mer je vais peut-être
laisser la parole à Madame j'ai pour
commencer et puis ensuite madame Louis
haute-barre
merci beaucoup
alors je ne sais pas si ma contribution
va être très intéressante parce que je
ne suis pas spécialiste des
questionnements que vous posez j'ai
essayé dans le lave de temps très court
de recueillir les observations des
confrères au moins sur sur le territoire
de Réunion Mayotte
que je connais mieux je n'ai pas eu
beaucoup de réponses parce que nous
sommes en période de congés scolaires
donc une contribution a été écrite vous
sera adressé je l'espère rapidement
les points de vue sont divergents sur
sur les questionnements les avocats font
du contentieux on défend des clients et
on a on peut avoir des points de vue qui
divergent selon les clients qui
représente plus ou moins de façon
habituelle donc sur le foncier
agricole
qu'est-ce que je pourrais vous dire sur
la protection le caractère suffisamment
protégé du foncier agricole point de vue
divergent vous avez les défenseurs de
constructeurs on va dire ou de
d'installateurs d'antenne téléphonique
qui considère que la protection est trop
forte naturellement et du côté du côté
agriculteur il y a eu récemment à la
Réunion
quelques communiqués les agriculteurs
qui considère que la protection n'est
pas suffisamment forte d'État agricoles
parce que
une petite autorisation peut rapidement
dériver vers la construction d'un
immeuble sur une terre à l'école donc ça
pose difficulté donc avis très
divergente selon la position dans
laquelle on se trouve naturellement il y
a de toute façon une pression
on va laisser très forte dans les doms
donc la question effectivement se pose
avec acuité de la protection des tas
agricoles la question ça va être comment
et ça on n'a pas forcément la solution
s'agissant
[Musique]
des dispositifs qui sont en place donc
on m'a parlé de l'appréhension de la
SAFER et de la alors de la SAFER et
aussi du du de la vie
décisionnaire cette fois de la cdpe9
[Musique]
ce qui m'est revenu comme comme
observation c'est que alors sur le
territoire réunionnais Mayotte j'ai pas
eu de réponse parce que la question se
pose de façon différente à Mayotte sur
le territoire réunionnais
comment vous dire ça
on me dit qu'il y a
une politique peut-être pas
[Musique]
pas très cohérente avec l'objectif on va
dire on me parle de
de condamnation notamment enfin
d'affirmation de rejet de l'annulation
des préemptions s'affaires qui ont pu
être effectués certaines évidemment je
parle pas généralité
parce que l'appréhension serait mal
exercé
au profit de certains peut-être on m'a
parlé de favoritisme mais bon ça après
c'est des prises qui peuvent être un peu
faussés par par la défense d'un
particulier je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas des critères qui sont qui sont
utilisés à tort ou déformés en tout cas
on m'a parlé de décision effectivement
j'en ai eu aussi de décision
d'annulation de préemption à faire qui
avait mal été exercée donc est-ce que
c'est un excès de zèle est-ce que c'est
une mauvaise application de la loi
est-ce que voilà ça je ne peux pas me
prononcer en tout cas
on a une impression d'après ce qui m'est
remonté encore une fois pas de
généralité mais sur certains cas on m'a
parlé de contrôle inapproprié
pas du tout sur le fond mais dans la sur
les préemptions qui ont été exercées en
tout cas
encore une fois
sur le dispositif CDAF donc nous avons
un système dérogatoire à la Réunion
enfin dans les domaines qui rend cet
avis non facultatif mais imposé
la vie devient obligatoire par contre il
doit être suivie dans les domaines donc
il y a un petit peu
une protestation de notre côté sur le
caractère dérogatoire
on s'interroge sur pourquoi pourquoi ce
système dérogatoire ou d'hommes et on
voudrait être traité de la même façon
que nationale impôt sur continent en
tout cas
voilà c'est ce qui m'est remonté immer
remonté également alors d'un côté
parfois un contrôle trop lourd et de
l'autre un contrôle
parfois mal
exercé encore une fois il y a des
suspicions de favoritisme mais bon ça
c'est toujours un petit peu le cas
voilà sur sur ces deux dispositifs
on me parle sur ce dispositif c'est des
pénards également
d'une certaine intransigence
qui vient piété sur les sur les pouvoirs
des mers
bon tout ça c'est une question à mon
sens de politique en fait ce qu'on veut
protéger est-ce qu'on peut protéger le
foncier agricole ou est-ce qu'on veut
autoriser l'urbanisme il y a une
pression mon avis sur du collectivité
qui n'est pas exercé la même façon sur
ces services peut-être plus indépendant
mais je ne connais pas assez la matière
pour pour me prononcer de façon très
claire pour ce qui me concerne
s'agissant des questions que vous posez
sur la juridiction spécialisée qui
serait une méthode de protection
du foncier vous avez posé la question
notamment
sur le dispositif particulier de
règlement des successions des
indivisions successorales par la loi le
Chili
donc cette loi elle est quand même
utilisée à la Réunion
quand même parce qu'il y a des
successions effectivement qui sont assez
anciennes
qui remontent parfois sur j'en ai vu sur
4 5 générations où les partages n'ont
pas été réglés parce qu'il y a des frais
de succession parce qu'on savait pas
parce que les notaires ont mal fait le
travail à l'époque parce qu'il y avait
pas de cadastre plein de raisons et donc
les partages sont pas effectués on doit
remonter sur cinq générations trois
générations très souvent sur trois
générations il faut retrouver les
indivisaires il faut avoir l'accord des
indivisaires il y a des occupations de
son titre il y a des prescriptions
acquisitives qui ont été faites
des situations assez complexes
il y a des blocages et c'est vrai que
régler ces systèmes par la loi les
chimie ça peut rester encore intéressant
à la Réunion en tout cas maintenant le
dispositif est pas toujours utilisé
d'accord parce que les avocats ne
connaissent pas forcément
systématiquement et les magistrats ne
connaissent pas non plus forcément on
m'a fait remonter à la hauteur des cas
où ça a été appliqué et ça a réglé la
situation juridique et autant des fois
où il y a eu des rejets c'est ce qui m'a
été remonter ce matin parce que les
magistrats n'appliquaient pas en fait le
dispositif donc est-ce qu'il faut le
prolonger à notre sens oui
est-ce qu'il faudrait peut-être le
préciser ou l'encadrer davantage
peut-être c'est à réfléchir
qu'avez-vous je sais plus ce que vous
aviez comme autre question
est-ce que est-ce que alors j'ai pas
j'ai pas toujours des réponses j'ai pas
de réponse notamment sur la primauté de
l'environnement
à l'agriculture j'ai pas forcément de
réponse précise c'est pas l'impression
qu'il ressort en tout cas
l'environnement est un droit qui a comme
toujours un peu du mal à être appliqué à
mon sens il y a une pression forte de
l'urbanisme surtout
étant l'environnement que le domaine
agricole est pas forcément surproté en
tout cas c'est pas c'est pas ce qui
remonte et c'est pas l'impression qu'on
en a d'ici
voilà vous aviez également posé la
question de l'application de la loi de
2006 sur le fond agricole pour moi il
s'applique donc il va falloir la Réunion
j'ai vu dans le texte il y a des
dérogations en Guyane à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon et à Mayotte
nous il s'applique régulièrement ça
fonctionne est-ce que c'est incitatif à
la transmission jeunes agriculteurs je
suis pas sûr que ce soit incitatif mais
en tout cas c'est utilisé
voilà je suis à votre disposition pour
des questions plus précises
vous pouvez passer au travers du
questionnaire dans les dans les grandes
lignes et puis par la suite nous faire
parvenir pour qu'on puisse vraiment s'en
inspirer dans le cadre du rapport voilà
c'est
comme vous comme vous le sentez et par
contre ça va simplement demander à
Maître g de couper son micro si elle
l'avait maintenu ouverte je crois de
l'avoir vu encore ouvert ce qui peut
amener de la perturbation voilà merci
beaucoup
en tout cas ce qui est ce qui est sûr tu
vas dire c'est qu'il y a autant de
d'outre-mer que de problèmes et il y a
autant de problèmes en Guadeloupe
particulièrement en Martinique
et que le foncier agricole constitue un
des problèmes économiques mais qu'un
problème important alors ce que je
voulais dire c'est que là dans les
contours sur la première question qui
vous dit la situation du foncier
agricole dans les outre-mer
j'avais noté les chiffres mais il y a
pour la Guadeloupe il y a 30000 il y a
64000 hectares de français agricoles
pour une surface agricole utile de 31000
hectares
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a quand même
pas mal de zones qui sont pas qui sont
exploitées les les
parcelles sont soit ce sont pas des
grandes passes ce sont pas des grandes
parcelles la en général ce sont des
agriculture pour la Guadeloupe en tout
cas et un peu moins pour la Martinique
mais qui est destiné plus à
l'exportation notamment la banane et un
peu plus en Martinique pour les pour les
fruits et légumes
alors les principaux contentieux enfin
je vais je vais reprendre ce qu'a dit
quasi Nathalie il faut pas contentieux
c'est effectivement c'est des passages
du cessoraux parce qu'il y a il y a il y
a un grand problème de de division
successorales il y a un grand problème
de titre de titre qui n'existe pas ceci
c'est un peu dur au passé au passé
d'esclaves de
l'histoire de notre esclavage puisque
après l'abolition de l'esclavage il y a
eu les anciens esclaves ont occupé en
tant que colon les terres ils les ont
exploités et les propriétaires terriens
ne se sont peu désintéressés et souvent
on voit par exemple que des gens qui
occupent qui occupent une parcelle
depuis
depuis des générations depuis trois
générations quelle génération et mais
qui n'a pas de titre et on voit souvent
que des héritiers qui qui arrivent et
qui découvrent dans une malle un type de
propriété et qui veulent à ce moment-là
récupérer leur parcelles donc moi j'ai
toujours en conflit entre le détenteur
le détenteur qui occupe que les derniers
occupants et le propriétaire et je sais
que la Cour de cassation donne souvent
raison ou détenteurs utile c'est-à-dire
que celui qui exploite celui qui fait
jouer la prescription acquisitive
[Musique]
les
le contentieux aussi c'est il y a
beaucoup de cas de fraude par exemple
vous aurez une pensée où il y a
souvent des gens qui n'ont pas de titre
mais il y a des héritiers mais il y en a
un qui est plus malin que les autres
donc il va vite se faire se faire
obtenir une un titre un titre jusqu'à
pion
et il y a beaucoup de recettes
d'héritage et ce qui est vrai et c'est
pour ça que la loi l'alchimie elle était
bien venue il y a beaucoup de
successions qui sont pas liquidés depuis
plusieurs générations et là où ce qu'on
regrette en fait c'est que la vie elle
était elle venait d'une d'une bonne
intention mais que les notaires souvent
ne jouent pas le jeu parce que ça fait
beaucoup de travail parce que les titres
sont anciens parce que les
héritiers sont difficiles à trouver les
unités ne sont pas tous sur le
territoire donc si bien que la loi la
chimie malgré tout le bien que pouvait
penser d'elle elle a peu d'écho
et pas simplement à cause de l'avocats
simplement à cause des magistrats mais
surtout à cause des notaires je pense
que là faudrait vraiment faire
il faudrait que d'un notaire aille sous
le terrain pour qu'ils expliquent
vraiment aux gens ce que la loi
on parlait de CDPE effectivement il y a
un avis conforme dérogatoire par rapport
aux Antilles à l'autre mère
consultatif la plupart des gens j'ai
interrogé ils sont tous contents de
cette avis conforme parce que ça ça
permet quand même aux communes au
département surtout aux communes de ne
pas de ne pas déclasser les termes pour
nous parce qu'on a quand même vu que
avec la spéculation immobilière il y a
beaucoup de terre qui était agricole qui
et brusquement deviennent déplacer parce
que le maire veut faire profiter un ami
un cousin d'une parcelle
voilà donc pour les indivision
successorales pour la loi l'alchimie bon
ben j'ai dit c'est
la bienvenue mais elle arrive à son
terme cette loi là parce que tu es prévu
pour 10 ans mais elle est pas elle est
pas elle est pas appliquée de manière
générale puisque avec tout ce qui se
passe en plus que j'avais pas du tout à
l'heure mais ça coûte très cher de
regarder une succession puisque comme
les héritiers sont loin comme les
héritiers on les connaît pas donc non
seulement on doit avoir un géomètre non
seulement on doit avoir un notaire mais
aussi on va voir en généraliste qui doit
chercher tous les héritiers
est-ce que je voulais dire aussi la
possibilité pour les exploitants
agricoles sera marin le consul de
l'habitation sur les terres moi je pense
que ça aussi ça ça contribue au
déplacement des terres parce qu'au
départ pour exploiter une parcelle il
faut avoir un gars avec de l'eau
l'électricité et puis longueur devient
une maison la maison devient une
deuxième maison après donc finalement
c'est c'est soi-disant au départ c'est
une exploitation agricole puisque j'ai
pour être exporter agricole il faut pas
grand chose mais vous êtes responsable
vous construisez votre maison sur sur la
parcelle agricole et il y a jamais eu de
cas je sais pas pour pour les autres
premiers en tout cas Martinique il y a
très peu de cas où les maires ont
ordonné la destruction de la maison de
la construction qui était faite sur une
parcelle agricole donc je pense que dans
ce cas là faudrait vraiment voir au cas
par cas
pour pour examiner parce que c'est vrai
que les exploitants agricoles en tout
cas ce que j'ai rencontré m'ont dit que
pendant les quand on élève des bovins
pour l'élevage c'est mieux d'être à
proximité de son élevage de se laisserai
pas ce que les les bêtes sont volées les
personnes tuées par des chiens des
choses comme ça de remettre à côté mais
encourager une construction sur une
pensée agricole boutique vous êtes
exploitant agricole je pense que ça va
aboutir à des abus donc je serai plutôt
pour examiner au cas par cas
alors la question importante enfin
surtout tu es importante la protection
de l'environnement au sein de
l'agriculture
c'est vrai aujourd'hui c'est vrai
aujourd'hui mais je vais c'est vrai
aujourd'hui et tant mieux puisque de
toute façon avec tout avec tout
l'écologie a pris a pris un important
sur tout le reste sur l'économie sur
l'agriculture mais je peux pas
m'empêcher de parler de cours d'école et
à ce moment-là on pensait pas à
l'écologie on pensait pas à
l'environnement on pensait plutôt à
l'agriculture donc c'est assez récent le
fait que l'environnement prenne le pas
sur l'agriculture
enfin les affaires les affaires le
problème de ça faire malgré toute la
bonne volonté des gens qui travaillent
malgré toute la compétence des
techniciens
ils subissent quand même ils ont un
problème de de moyen donc ils peuvent
pas toujours payer les parcelles qu'il
fréquentent
ils sont souvent mais ça c'est pas le
propre aux Antilles c'est pas propre à
l'Outre-mer c'est aussi sur le
territoire national donc les problèmes
financiers que connaissent à faire et
donc là ça fait ne peut pas toujours
exercer son problème son droit de
préemption
mais c'est important c'est important que
la SAFER existe ne serait-ce que pour
recenser les terres en friche pour
permettre de redonner aux jeunes
agriculteurs qui veulent s'installer et
puis s'exploiter et c'est important
aussi que la pour vérifier que tout se
passe selon les règles
voilà ce que je voulais dire en quelques
lignes
donc si je comprends bien mettre ce que
vous voulez de dire c'est que
l'environnement prend le pas sur les
terres agricoles
oui
le scandale du corps déconne ça a marqué
ça a marqué beaucoup le
les Antilles en tout cas les Martinique
et on fait très attention moi je suis je
fais toujours très attention même si je
sais que les continents à utiliser les
pesticides m'ont fait bien attention à
bien vérifier même si la production elle
est moindre mais en vérifie que rien ne
sera que rien ne sera contraire aux
règles aux règles de l'écologie l'eau on
essaie aussi de préserver l'eau on
essaie de préserver parce que les les
anti- enfin tout l'outre-mer et subi
quand même pas mal d'aller à thématiques
donc on sait que aujourd'hui on est bien
il y a le soleil tout va bien demain un
cyclone il y a plus de banane il y a
plus rien et on va souffrir pendant
pendant 10 ans donc il y a ça donc le
tous les problèmes tous les problèmes de
réchauffement climatique
on est suivi de plein fouet en tout cas
en guadeloupé en Martinique moi je vois
même même à l'oeil nu moi j'aurais des
îles où j'allais quand j'étais petite
elles ont disparu il y a juste au
cocotier qui est au milieu de l'eau donc
on voit on voit leur nu ces choses là
donc on est très sensibilisé et on veut
pas on veut pas en tout cas c'est le
sentiment que que au motif de se
retrouver d'avoir une autonomie agricole
qu'on produise à tout va
lors de notre déplacement la Martinique
on nous a fait quand même entendre que
l'ONF avait un poids très important
pas spécialement sur les pesticides mais
bon par exemple
il demande des taxes quand vous voulez
récupérer des terrains frises et ils
appliquent des taxes importantes parfois
qui empêche finalement les gens de les
prendre pour faire de l'agriculture
c'est peut-être un petit peu dommage
c'est un accès et la peur l'importance
de l'ONF est surtout présente Guyane
avec avec la forêt mais qui n'est
presque pas exploité parce que justement
il faut pas toucher au détriment des
agriculteurs mais
un peu bon vous savez on est des on est
des territoires des territoires pauvres
des territoires économiquement faibles
mais on est on a une conscience on n'a
pas vu une conscience du développement
que nous arrive par par les pays riches
en tout cas donc on n'a pas envie vous
savez le corps des femmes c'est quelque
chose je sais pas si vous en a parlé que
vous étiez en Martinique mais à tout
bout de champ
on entend ça on entend et et on s'est
dit que au motif qu'il fallait produire
des bananes saines
[Musique]
donc ils n'ont pas hésité alors que ce
produit était interdits ils étaient à
polluer pour des générations pour des
générations pour des années à venir
90% des terres enveloppés en Martinique
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un dispositif
de fond agricole sur le modèle du fond
de commerce pour être institué pour
faciliter la transmission des
exploitations et d'un point de vue
général comment faciliter et accompagner
l'installation de jeunes agriculteurs
alors je sais pas ça s'adresse à toutes
les deux enfin je commence oui oui à
toutes les deux à toutes les deux oui
bah je pense oui je pense que ce serait
je pense que ce serait une bonne idée et
même dans le dans le principe de la du
portage successoral ce serait bien que
on décide comment on fait par exemple
celui qui a qui qui
le boulanger ben il bénéficie du fonds
de commerce de la boulangerie de son
père donc je pense que faudrait aussi
encourager la préférence ou celui la
préférence agricole pour celui qui
exploite déjà je pense que c'est déjà
mis en place plus ou moins
est-ce que Madame j'ai veux rajouter
quelque chose
oui de toute façon toute mesure
d'encouragement et d'en apprendre je
pense plus à des mesures
financières fiscales etc parce que pour
la transmission il y a effectivement le
régime de l'attribution préférentielle
si je le m'abuse qui s'applique déjà
donc pour l'exploitant qui est sur place
dans le cas d'une succession d'un décès
donc pour moi ce serait plus une
incitation
dans la fiscalité de la transmission qui
pourrait être mise en place si vous
voulez favoriser ça
s'agissant de l'environnement de notre
côté on n'a pas on n'a pas cette
cette polémique environnementale qui a
qui a gravement touché
le territoire adolanique donc c'est vrai
que chez nous c'est moins fort moi j'ai
pas la même vision sur notre territoire
de d'une prédominance de l'environnement
et les attentions particulières de
l'environnement ce qui a chez nous c'est
une pression de l'urbanisme sur les
terres agricoles
le foncier de protection l'ONF
versus agriculture face à se passe
plutôt bien à ma connaissance j'ai pas
de j'ai pas de contentieux là dessus
s'agissant de la question également de
la construction sur état agricole de la
maison de l'exploitant les avis sont
très partagés Yannick disait tout à
l'heure du cas par cas ça c'est
compliqué au niveau législatif
l'autoriser les agriculteurs certains
agriculteurs sont très en demande de la
possibilité de construire leur
habitation sur la terre agricole parce
que ça leur permet effectivement de
surveiller le bétail de surveiller
l'exploitation les champs
qui sont
qui sont exposés donc à la visite des
personnes qui viennent courir se
promener etc ou de vol tout simplement
on a des vols notamment de coeur de
Palmy ces choses comme ça ça c'est assez
récurrent les voies dans les tribunaux
correctionnels donc ça permettrait une
surveillance le problème c'est que
lorsqu'on a autorisé alors il y a eu une
époque il y a quelques années enfin je
parle d'une époque il y a 15 ans voire
plus ou il y avait des tolérances des
communes des services de l'urbanisme des
communes qui autorisaient
ou en tout cas qui me démolissait pas
des constructions qui a été faites avec
ou sans permis sur des exploitations
agricoles
c'était une tolérance sa tolérance a
pris fin et il y a moi j'ai connaissance
de cas de démolition qui ont eu lieu ces
dernières années à l'initiative de la
communauté ou pas mais en tout cas qui
sont arrivés devant les juridictions
pénales et qui ont donné lieu à des
destructures pourquoi parce que c'est ce
que disait Yannick tout à l'heure
lorsqu'il y a une construction sur des
terres agricoles il y a potentiellement
il y en a eu des abus des abus ce serait
une construction de plusieurs maisons à
vocation locative s'il y a déjà de
l'immobilier là-dessus donc un
déclassement des terres puisqu'elles
sont plus purement agricoles et donc ça
devient à moitié constructive puis
complètement constructive et donc il y a
grignotage comme ça des terres agricoles
qui se fait ça s'est fait dans le passé
donc il y a une crainte à avoir de façon
très certaine si on autorise à nouveau
ces constructions il y a eu de
manifestation chez nous il y a pas
longtemps ou en tout cas des articles de
presse l'agriculteurs qui se plaignaient
parce que des immeubles se construisent
sur les terres agricoles et ça ça dérive
de ce genre justement d'autorisation ou
de tolérance qui ont pu avoir lieu de
construction sur les terres agricoles
alors où mettre le curseur c'est
compliqué
c'est une question difficile à encadrer
en tout cas mais même l'encadrement
paraît compliqué parce que il y a
toujours cette pression de l'urbanisme
en tout cas chez nous à la Réunion qui
est extrêmement forte
voulait poser une question oui oui
bonjour je souhaiterais savoir si vous
avez eu des situations pour des
personnes qui sont installées sur des
GFA et qui
ne souhaitent pas partir même quand ils
sont déjà arrivés à l'âge de la retraite
et que leurs enfants même quand ils sont
pas agriculteurs pardon souhaite
poursuivre et garder le foncier alors
est-ce que vous avez des situations de
ce type là et l'autre l'autre chose
c'est aussi pour l'installation des
éoliennes je voudrais savoir également
si vous avez des situations des cas où
pour l'installation d'éoliennes on
utilise du foncé agricole en dépit du
fait que les agriculteurs eux-mêmes
souhaitent poursuivre la culture sur les
terres concernées merci
c'est une question très précise
c'est vrai que bon
je les éoliennes c'est c'est quelque
chose qu'on déteste voir on est d'accord
que c'est utile que c'est une énergie
renouvelable on est d'accord que c'est
une énergie du futur mais enfin c'est
quand même ça détruit vraiment la la le
paysage
alors je pense que la
c'est une question de priorité de
balance faut savoir c'est comme c'est
comme exproprier des agriculteurs pour
faire passer le TGV donc c'est le même
principe on se dit que qu'est-ce qui est
plus important prendre une petite
parcelle à un agriculteur qui souvent se
sont des terres en friche qui fait pas
et pour permettre de d'alimenter en
énergie
toute une ville
souvent on choisit
qui était indemniser l'agriculteur qui
était analysé la pose des laurier
personnellement j'ai pas vu de j'ai pas
vu j'ai pas vu le contentieux sur ça
s'agissant de ton autre question sur le
fait que l'agriculteur est très vieux il
veut pas il veut pas partir il veut pas
laisser le ça ça arrive souvent quand
même parce que les agriculteurs ne
portent pas la retraite
donc ils ont du mal à laisser la place
alors à leurs enfants
qui sont plus moderne ça c'est vrai et
enfin bon ça c'est pas pareil
j'ai répondu à tes deux questions
je pense que oui on est à moi j'en ai
une autre qui est un peu plus technique
d'ailleurs et c'est plus vraiment une
interrogation en général sur la CD P9
en lien est-ce que ce que Maître G a
évoqué tout à l'heure avez-vous eu
connaissance que cette disparité de
traitement sur la nature de la ville la
CD pennaf entre les domaines et
l'hexagone et fait l'objet ou pas d'un
d'une
QPC devant la juridiction administrative
par exemple parce que on pourrait
entendre effectivement qu'il y a pas de
raison qu'on outremer c'est à vie
c'est un avis conforme effectivement
ouais tout à fait donc la question
simplement savoir si il y avait déjà eu
un contentieux administratif au cours
duquel une QPC était soulevée dans le
Conseil constitutionnel pour juger de de
l'inconstitutionnalité de ce qui
visiblement soulève beaucoup des mois
dans nos outre-mer
ça fait longtemps en fait il existe
depuis quelques années donc je pense
qu'il était déclaré comment la
Constitution c'est pas la seule
dispositif qui est dérogatoire
entre le maire et la
et le territoire national moi les
agriculteurs que j'ai rencontrés enfin
j'ai rencontré ceux qui étaient à la
Chandeleur on dit qu'ils étaient quand
même contents que ce soit un avis
conforme parce que il se méfiait il se
méfait de leurs élus
c'est un effet de leurs élus et Nathalie
parlait de de l'urbanisation à outrance
c'est bon c'est un peu le cas mais
peut-être pas autant qu'à la Réunion
mais ce qui se passe souvent c'est que
le tourisme ce sont des îles des îles à
touristes donc pour permettre de faire
des des
de faire des belles maisons qui vont
servir de d'Égypte à des vacanciers
les les mers serez capables de de
déplacer certaines terres et des
agriculteurs égyptiennes ils y tiennent
en tout cas le l'institution de la
chandelle
moi je rejoins Yannick je on a on a
l'habitude des mesures dérogatoire par
principe
on se repose toujours la question de
pourquoi du bien fondé de la des mesures
dérogatoires c'est toujours un petit peu
agaçant mais malgré tout je rejoins
quand même Yannick sur le sur le fond
c'est à dire que la CdP et quand même le
job
[Musique]
protège protège les terres agricoles ça
c'est certain donc
elle a quand même une certaine utilité
au plan local pour répondre de questions
tout à l'heure alors non je me souviens
plus forcément mais il y en avait une
sur
les éoliennes alors nous c'est les
éoliennes ça ne me parle pas en revanche
on a le soleil et on a les antennes
téléphoniques chez nous
avec des antennes vous savez les
opérateurs
payent les propriétaires pour implanter
donc c'est un bail
et secours sur 15 ans en général je
crois où on implante une ampaine donc
c'est du béton
avec des ondes et ça prend quand même
une petite surface parce que il y a des
trucs de sécurité d'entretien etc et
donc il y a eu une on m'a parlé d'une
d'une noix dérogatoire expérimentale de
2000 décembre 2022 c'est tout frais il y
a déjà du contentieux donc cette loi
[Musique]
se exonaire en fait des antennes de cet
avis conforme de la CD pénard et ben
tout de suite les opérateurs se sont mis
en place il y a eu des avis négatifs et
il y a eu des recours qui ont été
écartés et donc les antennes construites
sur la terre agricole voilà donc ça tout
de suite l'urbanisme prend le pas le
solaire à un moment donné il y a eu
effectivement des installations sur des
champs c'est lui aussi en métropole
après à ma connaissance c'est vite passé
on est parti sur les couvertures de toit
ou les ou les parkings il y a eu cette
expérimentation là je n'ai pas entendu
parler pour ma part de
de construction
de ce type là sur les terrains agricoles
en tout cas
je me souvenais plus qu'elle était
l'autre question pardon
ou peut-être que j'ai répondu
particulière sur ces sur ces questions
là pour moi je l'ai jamais rencontré on
en a pas parlé donc il y a pas de
problème de transmission de ce point de
vue là
ma connaissance
favorables ou défavorables ne peuvent
pas faire l'objet de recours de votre
administratif ce qu'on peut faire c'est
c'est la permission qui a été
autorisation qui a été donnée peut faire
un recours dans l'administratif je pense
pas que le soit débordé pendant ce genre
de contentieux
bien écoutez je vous remercie beaucoup
mettre pour pour ces éclairages fort
utiles et comme nous l'avons dit en
début de d'audition si vous avez des
contributions et notamment les réponses
aux questionnaires à nous adresser par
par écrit nous sommes évidemment
preneurs pour pouvoir enrichir nos
travaux et surtout compléter les travaux
que les rapporteurs sont en train de
mener en tout cas merci beaucoup de ces
éclairages et de votre disponibilité et
je vous souhaite une bonne fin de
journée merci infiniment
au revoir à bientôt au revoir